thank you
uh good morning everyone my name is
Teresa Woodruff and I serve as the
interim president at Michigan State
University and through the tragic week
that we've all experienced we've thanked
many people who have uh Been
instrumental in the response and the
recovery to Monday night's horrific
events and one group that we haven't yet
thanked is the media and so at the
outset today I want to offer my thanks
on behalf of a grateful University to
all of you who helped spread the photo
of the shooter on Monday night that led
to the tip that came in and the
conclusion of this event you helped our
community you helped our state and you
helped our nation stay informed and
allowed us to be more transparent as we
all worked and walked together on this
pathway so I wanted to begin today just
with a thank you to everyone in the
media for help helping to spread that
essential And Timely information
others today in this news conference are
going to provide updates on the
investigation and law enforcement
matters and so my comments are going to
be brief and they're going to focus on
three areas first where are we now
what's next and the process that's going
to guide our decisions as we move
forward as you'll soon hear
the five students at Sparrow are still
in critical condition but I'm pleased
that we are seeing some signs of
improvement in some of our students and
our Spartan Nation continues to send
good thoughts to each of them to their
families and to the doctors and nurses
at Sparrow Hospital
as I've said before grief is a
profoundly personal thing and we know
from trauma experts and from truck
talking to colleagues at other
universities who have experienced
similar tragedies everyone Grieves
differently and the recovery process
isn't linear so each member of our
campus will have different needs and our
focus is on providing as much
flexibility as possible in supporting
the diverse needs of this Campus
Community so as we move forward I ask
the campus and everyone in our Spartan
Community an extended family is
represented here to provide empathy and
grace and the knowledge that each
person's support may be different and we
will be considerate of that
I'm extremely grateful for the quick
actions that we've had pulling together
the many counseling and support services
this week we know that many in the
community will continue to need services
for months to come and that some haven't
reached out yet but I am encouraged that
and can be report that hundreds of
students have already utilized our
counseling services that were provided
at the Hannah Community Center or in our
residence Halls we also provided a
service to employees that is called
reflect and connect and we're looking
for looking into training for
supervisors as more faculty and staff
began returning to positions today and
into next week we are encouraging
empathy and patience and an atmosphere
for all to recover at their own pace and
will continue to offer these Services
into the future today MSU is resuming
standard operations
after 48 Hours of being in modified
operations while we are returning to
standard operations classes remain
suspended through Sunday this standard
operations means that the university
offices are open but in this case with
wide latitude provided to supervise
across our University Network the two
buildings Berkey remains closed for the
remainder of the semester the second
building the union is still being
evaluated for decisions to be reported
later FBI special agent in charge of
Michigan Jim tarasca will report in just
a moment on access to those buildings
for students faculty and staff who still
have materials that are present in those
spaces
leaders across campus have been mating
with a variety of the groups that have
been impact impacted from our families
of those that we have lost as well as
those who are bravely recovering at
Sparrow we've also been talking with our
students faculty and staff who are in
the class of the shooter in Berkey Hall
and the employees who were in The Union
on Monday night we are listening and we
are supporting at all levels our core
leadership team is meeting daily and we
will continue to do so to prioritize the
needs of Campus we want to be supportive
not only of our campus but we understand
that the community is involved and we
want to give people the confidence to
re-engage and stay engaged as we come
together
our Alumni network over 500 000 Spartans
strong are contacting us and wanting to
get involved they are generously
donating their time and items that can
be helpful to the community including
fifteen thousand candles last night as
well as flowers that were associated
with our vigil for those who want to
give in a way that can support MSU at
this time we have set up a fund called
Spartan strong fund and you can find
that on the MSU website and chief Lynch
has also told me of the many people who
have dropped off food and other items to
our msupd and we are all very grateful
for that outpouring of love and support
and as I understand it we're out of
kitchen space at this point so we thank
you for that outpouring in so many ways
we know as a campus that we have hard
work ahead of us moving forward won't be
easy
unfortunately others in higher education
have been through this and we are
connecting in ways that through these
shared experiences we will have ideas
about how we can evaluate our best plans
forward and as we move forward from
today we will work together to make
informed decisions and lean on each
other none of us have all the answers
but we do have each other
so at this point I'd like to turn this
briefing over to our chief of police and
Adjunct professor in our school of
Criminal Justice Marlon Lynch Marlin
thank you President Woodrow good morning
um I'd like to start with some thanks to
Outreach by our colleagues our local
Partners but also some well-established
associations the Michigan Association
Chiefs of police the international
Chiefs of police
the International Association of Campus
law enforcement administrators and the
commission Agency on law enforcement
accreditation we have all received your
support prayers and thanks and um
very well valued so thank you for that
in addition to that
I decided to focus on some positive
things some positive things that have
been shared with me over the past couple
days with that
in helping us in our response
to this critical incident
we had approximately 19 law enforcement
agencies and six fire departments
numerous Emergency Medical Services as
well respond to that
we had off-duty police officers not only
from our police department but from
local and partnering agencies that
responded
that came without a request
to help during that particular situation
not a surprise though
what occurred on Monday night as far as
our response is a collaborative effort
and is the product of constant and
continuous training together
relationships and preparation for that
we also unfortunately
had an opportunity to respond last week
to Old Miss High School
with a very similar result the
difference is that was not confirmed and
it was willed to be false
so just imagine the stress put on the
First Responders
responding to a situation at Okemos High
School
that
you take very seriously until otherwise
notified
and then just a few days later
responding to this incident here
we have to recover too we have to heal
that process has begun as well
we've made services available for our
staff our police and Public Safety staff
beginning today we also have short-term
plans as well as long-term plans as we
move forward for this and we are
definitely Consulting those that have
been through this process before
that particular reason
learned a few amazing things and again
not surprising just knowing what has
occurred and who's involved
our students that were in Berkey Hall
in addition
to being placed in situations that they
probably have never
been encountered with before
when they're students and their friends
and classmates needed assistance they
rendered Aid
they took the time to render Aid with
that
the officers that responded and was in
the buildings within minutes
one of the first things they encountered
were the victims so those victims happen
to be our students
and they stopped to render Aid and
immediately got Emergency Medical
Services on scene to remove them so that
they could get the treatment and the
care that they needed
those are significant because they gave
them a chance those that had been
wounded
and they're still fighting but based on
based on those being present at the time
stopping to actually render Aid to them
good dispatchers
dispatch function is a very key
component to what we do our response and
if any of you have heard any of the
radio traffic
that happened that night it's amazing
they were calm they prioritize
they communicated well
they did their job
they did their job and extremely well
extremely well
my point in this is to say that it's not
based on an individual
we all have roles
when it comes time to actually do what
you've been trained to do
that happen and there's a carrying
component as well
some very selfless
and stopping to assist when they could
have easily have just run out
of the building themselves and there was
nothing wrong with that at all that's
part of how they're actually trained
our students they receive they have the
opportunity to receive that training and
run hide fight
and unfortunately some of them during
their high school years Middle School
years think about the generation that's
here now they've had to go through that
they've had to go through that
so
I found that positive to be able to
communicate that with that those are
some stories that need to be discussed
as well
and hopefully that is actually what what
takes place which some has already done
that but I think we needed to take a
moment to actually state that the
appreciation for that
so while we were here now will be
updates
um in addition to the Michigan State
University Police and Public Safety uh
representative that's here uh We've also
have Lansing Police Department
Michigan State Police as well as the FBI
come with updates and again we
appreciate your presence here with that
deputy chief Roswell thank you
good morning everybody thank you chief
uh I want to begin by again honoring the
the victims our students
as a father I cannot imagine what all
the families continue to go through
the past few days have been so
unbelievably difficult
for our officers and our community
and we continue to mourn
with our community and um start the
healing process
the vigil last night
was unbelievable the the turnout
we want to thank our Michigan State
Police partners for providing security
at that event
so our MSU police officers could attend
and be with our community and mourn
together and that event truly was
unbelievable how many people came from
all over the country for that event
I'm going to start with some brief
updates and then I'm going to hand it
off to some of our law enforcement
partners that are here today to at to
offer additional details
we've received questions about the ages
of the deceased students
and
those are as follows
Ariel Anderson was 19 years old
Ryan Frazier was 20 years old
and Alexandria Verner was also 20 years
old
we were present yesterday when they were
recognized in the chamber of the
Michigan House of Representatives
and that was a very moving experience as
well
as the president mentioned the five
students in the hospital remain in
critical condition
out of respect for the families we will
not be releasing the names of the
victims
in the hospital
we do understand that some of those
names have been made public by family
and friends
but we feel strongly about not
confirming their names out of respect
for the families and we hope you
understand
so even though MSU police and Public
Safety is the lead agency in charge of
this investigation
the investigation is very complex it's
bifurcated and involves many different
agencies
different parts of that investigation
are being handled by different agencies
in a very unified and coordinated effort
the unit that unified cooperation
between all of the agencies involved
and the resources that have been
deployed to campus from all over the
country it is impressive
I'll share a few brief updates regarding
the investigation
and some of our partners that are here
today will elaborate on some of these
details as well
we can confirm that the shooter had two
handguns on his person when he was
located
those handguns are both nine millimeter
he also had additional magazines and
ammunition on his person
our investigative team did work with our
federal ATF Partners to trace those
weapons
and we have learned that they were
purchased legally
by the shooter but they were not
registered
we can also confirm that a note was
found on the shooter
and the location that the shooter was
located
was roughly 3.8 miles Northwest of
Campus
as I said the Michigan State Police is
here today and they will share
additional information about that
shooting scene
we want to thank all of our local County
state and federal partners
for all of their assistance that they
provided throughout this investigation
the investigative assistants that we've
received after the initial incident has
been absolutely overwhelming as well
as the interim president said we'd also
like to thank the media for being active
Partners throughout this investigation
your ability to share our information
while understanding the sensitive nature
and having compassion for the families
is very much appreciated
at this time I'm going to turn it over
to Lieutenant Renee Gonzalez from the
Michigan State Police
we will be available for questions at
the end
thank you definitely Chief Osmond
information I'm going to give out as uh
dealing with the contact that LPD had
LBT and LPD MSU
I'm sorry LPD MSP and our State security
officers had contact with the shooter at
Lake Lansing and large Road
the uh our detectives responded to Lake
Lansing Road and Larch Street where a
subject matching the msu's shooting
suspect Anthony McRae was observed
walking
what had happened is the LPD officers
received a call that subject matching
that description was walking down the
street this was on Lake Lansing Road
near large Street city of Lansing
officers made contact two LPD officers
made contact with the shooter
approximately 20 feet from McRae
they exited their vehicle ordered him to
put his show his hands however he
produced a weapon and then killed
himself
it does appear that from the body worn
camera that McRae did not verbalize
anything to the officers prior to him
shooting himself
or taken his own life once they had
waited for two additional State security
officers to arrive on scene they walked
up to the shooter who was laying on the
ground
cleared the scene for their safety and
then started life-saving uh efforts on
him however he was declared deceased at
the scene after that two other state
troopers also showed up on scene our
detectives arrived on scene they
conducted interviews with the officers
on scene photographed the area
downloaded body worn cameras in-car
videos and did round columns for all the
officers to ensure that no no rounds
were fired
on scene again were two Troopers two
Capital security officers two Lansing
Township PD Officers and also uh two LPD
officers
search was done after the scene was
Secure of mcrae's residence with a
search warrant that was authored by
msupd along with LPD
at the residence a cell phone was
collected journals of sorts
miscellaneous writings and fired nine
millimeter casings mcrae's father was
also interviewed unseen by the MSP
Detectives
at the Lansing operations building
once the search of the residence was
completed the detectives began a
surveillance canvas to attempt to
track the shooters
once he cleared the MSU campus until he
made contact with the uh with the LPD
officers
they were able to track his uh his
his
Journey from the MSU campus to where he
was made contact they are conducting
additional surveillance canvases to see
if we can find anything else on where he
might have been
detectives are also assisting with
downloading information from mcrae's
phone following up on uh cata there's
two additional uh
bus tickets were found in his possession
McRae were two handguns
the one he shot himself with and another
in his backpack that he was carrying he
also had a loaded magazine that was full
to capacity in his left breast pocket
in the backpack he had eight loaded
magazines of nine millimeter ammunition
along with a pencil size pouch
containing 50 rounds of loose nine
millimeter ammunition he also had two
empty magazines on his person as well
two pages of notes were found in his
wallet which was on his person as well
those are the uh that was the note that
indicated
where he was going to visit
and also kind of gave an indication of
why he maybe a motive but nothing that
we can actually confirm just yet uh the
investigation is ongoing and at this
time we believe that there were no other
subjects involved and McRae was the Lone
shooter in this incident
and I'll turn it over to Chief Silsby
thank you lieutenant good morning
everybody my name is Ellery Silsby I'm
the chief of police in Lansing
I'm going to start by saying that the
Lansing Police Department through mayor
Shore's office is assisting in this
investigation as much as possible to
make sure that we have complete closure
in the sense that I want to start by
giving my condolences to the family of
the victims of this tragic incident
being a father of a son who is recently
accepted to this great University I
can't even imagine the pain that the the
families are feeling right now
I want to thank the officers who
responded without pause to this critical
incident many of those as has been
mentioned before were off due and
dropped everything they were doing to
come assist to make sure that there were
no more losses of life
and to prevent this tragedy from getting
any larger
I want to thank the citizens who along
with the media's help
saw something and said something
without them
we may not be in this position here
today
I'd like to clear up just a few things a
few topics of misinformation that we
have been asked about about either the
accused McRae or the address the Lansing
address on Howe Street in the city of
Lansing
LPD has not responded to any welfare
checks for Anthony McRae
there was a welfare check at the address
on Howell Street on February 5th but was
not related to the accused
and LPD has not been called in any way
to any shots fired at this address
the call history for the accused in this
situation is very limited
but I will share this with you now to
hopefully avoid any questions in the
future
starting back in 2005
McRae was contacted for a larceny
complaint by the Lansing Police
Department
2006 the traffic violation 2007 a
traffic violation 2007 again another
traffic violation and in 2019 he was
arrested by the Lansing Police
Department for CCW which is a caring
concealed weapon which he was arrested
for
and for that case that weapon is still
in Lansing Police Department custody
as Lieutenant shared two Lansing Police
Officers made contact with the accused
in approximately the 800 block of Lake
Lansing Road and the accused was
contacted
he produced a handgun
and ended his own life
I cannot commend the officers enough for
their actions
and
um I'd be open for questions here at the
end but for now I'm going to turn it
over to FBI especially in charge James
Raska
good morning
I will start off by thanking the press
as well
over the last few days I've gotten to
know quite a few of you as we just talk
offline and actually socialize while
this this event continues so Paul you
thank you you've been very supportive
and I appreciate that sort of pseudo our
folks
so today at Berkey Hall we'll uh we'll
continue meeting with students and staff
to return their personal items that were
left behind
so that process essentially uh will
begin at 10 and the students can show up
they will meet with our victims
Specialists and agents and um
not only will they be able to get their
items back they will uh they'll be able
to meet with our victim Specialists for
mental health support not just FBI and
we've flown victim specialists in from
around the country
MSU has provided victim Services as well
victim Specialists are there commute the
students the U.S attorney's Office
Western District of Michigan is
represented HSI is also represented so
we have a great Cadre of mental health
professionals there to support the
students we did the same at Union
yesterday
I would consider it a success in that
the students did want to sit with our
folks and talk along those lines I want
to thank the community especially those
who brought Comfort dogs yesterday it
went a long way it meant a lot to
students and our folks as well the
Comfort dogs uh they bring a lot so
thank you to everybody that took the
time to do that
uh the property that will return to them
essentially it's a pretty easy process
they'll identify what's theirs will
return it for this those students that
don't want to be there don't want to go
in that building that's fine just
understand you don't have to do that we
will get your property to you you can
come
not go in the building talk to our folks
and they'll get it to you or after today
everything that's left over everything
that remains it hasn't been collected
will be turned over to MSU
Police Department so they can coordinate
and facilitate getting those items back
to you yesterday about 80 percent of the
students and staff's items were returned
we're left I believe the number is about
18 students that did not pick up their
things for certain reasons where they
couldn't make it or just didn't want to
we have those items today at Berkey so
for those students that maybe yesterday
they can go to Berkey and again after
today they can reach out directly to MSU
as we start to uh start to wrap up again
the community outpouring has been
amazing through food and just thank yous
and handshakes and um that's very very
much appreciated because goes a long way
with with all our folks and the whole
Community here
I do want to thank Governor Whitmer
and congresswoman slacken for their
ongoing support they've been uh they've
been obviously extremely supportive
there here at the press conference the
other day and the congresswoman is I
believe going to do a site visit today
to meet with our folks and the students
as well so we uh look forward to hosting
her
even after today the FBI will continue
supporting the families of Alex Arielle
and Brian doesn't stop today those
Services we provide the support we
provide will continue we've met with
those families
and we've began to build a relationship
with them so we will be there for them
along with all our partners they have
our full support for the students that
remain in the hospital same thing they
will have the full support of all the
FBI and uh all the partners here
I just want to mention that a number for
the United Way for additional mental
health support for anybody listening
that would uh like to utilize at 2-1-1
if you dial 2-1-1 you can get support so
that's a just another Outlet there's a
lot of resources so please for for
everybody the students faculty the
community there's there's plenty of
resources to help you and help the
community recover
so with that doctor alternative to you
thank you
good morning my name is Dr Lima Vassar
I'm the chair at MSU
the Board of Trustees and I come to you
today as both the chair and the mother
of a Spartan
who was on campus
um
the day that the shooter came and took
so much from us but also took our sense
of safety
I have this dual role as I'm going
through this with the Spartan community
and it's a
it's an identity that allows me to see a
lot of empathy in people and a lot of
Grace and I'm so grateful to the
community who has been supportive in
ways that we just
couldn't imagine
that evening
my daughter called
and uh
she she joked I said this later today
she said um this that's the first time
we ever answered my call that fast
generally she calls for money so
um she might not get me on the first
ring but I answered right away and she
said that's when I knew it was real she
sheltered in place in a bathroom for
three hours waiting for this to end and
as I'm taking the updates from campus
I'm also Fielding her calls my family's
calls who are all trying to figure out
is she okay am I okay is everyone okay
I want to commend
I want to commend Chief Lynch
you have organized and coordinated
services in ways that um
I I didn't imagine all these folks
coming together to make sure that our
Spartan Community feels safe has been
enlightening in so many ways but also
just reassuring
even last night at the visual
my daughter had not been on campus since
Monday but I convinced her to come
immediately when I got on the stairs she
started to text me Mom I feel safe I
want you to get down
there are people who are kneeling I'm
not sure what's happening
so I texted her
um to get to the chief
you know him
get next to him you'll be safe
I know people took exception to that
text I I don't know what you would have
done if that were your daughter
I want us to give the grace that's
necessary we all are going to be healing
in different ways in different Paces I'm
one of those mothers who's like tough it
up you know you can you scrape your knee
you want peroxide or alcohol like I'm
one of those moms right
um but I'm giving my daughter who is a
kind
key cool kid a lot of Grace and I want
that grace extended to all students all
staff and all faculty
the board has gone to talk with
Ariel's
parents Alexandria's parents Brian's
parents
heart-wrenching
discussions
our hearts go out to them we have
offered all our services to them we also
went to Sparrow to meet with the
families whose
children are fighting for their lives
right now today
and it was amazing how gracious they
were
they're asking how we're doing
I mean just the sparrow Community has
been
absolutely amazing that was the quote
from
one of the fathers and so I'm grateful
to them
for their service to these these
families this is a hard time a tough
time but we're going to get through it
in the coming days the board will
continue to meet with the administration
we'll continue to get updates from Chief
Lynch around what has happened
debriefing what we know to be true what
could be different
going forward and we also are meeting
with faculty staff and students around
their issues of safety and where they
felt disabled and why right and how we
can we can recreate those kinds of
places all around campus the board is
committed to making sure that we are
united on the other end of this and that
Spartans from all over the globe can
come to this campus and feel like they
will be safe
we will not have our Safety and Security
stolen
by a man with a gun
in the senses act of violence it will
not happen
I will open it up to questions and turn
it back over
and I tell you what before we open it up
for questions I do just want to
highlight that you know again this
investigation that's ongoing is so
massively complex that you may have
questions that we know the answer to the
folks up here today just might not have
that information so please be patient
with us we will do our best to uh answer
all of your questions we have remained
committed to being transparent and
sharing as much information from the
very beginning and that remains please
understand that as we move forward
there's so many questions that you have
we may have to to get that answer and
get back to you so with that I'll open
it up to questions for any of the
speakers that are here today in the back
go ahead
graduate
first question what's on your heart
today
we are a Resolute community
it's on my heart
is what is my task that I accepted
almost two years ago
to return to my alma mater
to and I questioned what attracts me
besides my love for I miss you
I know why I'm here today
I know I'm here today to help
to help be a part of what we have in
existence here as a community
and what we have in our Partnerships
these relationships are not new
these have been in place for years
and the amazing thing is that
I'm I'm an alum
Chris is in the law
elorism alone the sheriffs and the law
the chief of Meridian Township is it
alone
we could go on and on with that
we are truly invested in what we have
here
and we're going to keep it but it opens
discussions for how we perceive and how
we create that environment it's just not
up to us
we're going to have discussions with our
community and this is a societal
challenge as well
and real quickly
quickly businesses for example the
church the warehouse that was listed in
the snow did he have ties to the places
that were named in the note
reference the note with the listing of
the businesses through our investigation
we found that he had had contact with
some of those places
he was an employee of the Meyer
warehouse at one time
in a couple of other businesses it
appears that he'd had some issues with
the employees there where he was asked
to leave so it looks like he possibly a
motive for that was he just felt
slighted and that's kind of what the
note indicated
um but why did it take three hours to
get that out like do you have real-time
monitoring of cameras on campus what was
the process eventually
yeah that's a good question you know we
have thousands of cameras on this campus
um we've worked uh recently to enhance
that even further
um there that system is is complex
um and our investigators immediately
began reviewing surveillance footage
um it did take them a little bit of time
to locate that
um due to the number and the volume of
cameras that we have uh and we didn't
know what his path was at that point we
didn't know which door he exited we
didn't know which route he took uh we
didn't know where he went after he left
those buildings when our officers
arrived on scene at both of those
locations he had already left the
building we didn't know by by which
direction which door and so we
immediately began reviewing uh
surveillance footage as soon as we
captured as soon as we located that
image we immediately pushed it out
immediately pushed it out on social
media my understanding is that the
caller actually saw it I wanted the news
stations and so we've already said this
but we can't thank our partners enough
for for amplifying that and then 17
minutes later we received the phone call
through our Dispatch Center that he uh
he was seeing so while I know the timing
um you know people may question the
timing this was a ongoing complex
incident
um and it took a little bit of time to
find that image but uh we we worked
valiantly and I commend our
investigators uh that
set their rifles down and turned around
and started looking at a video on the on
the computer
um to locate those those images
yeah
so that's um
part of our overall strategic plan is to
we are currently in a process of
centralizing all security systems that
will accompany or will come with
real-time monitoring which is what
you're speaking of is when uh an example
would be in a situation like that the
location would be identified uh be
operator would know that that particular
location has X number of cameras and
began automatically pulling the cameras
out to help with the overall response
for that that's something that's in
development that was an initiative that
we announced in the fall with that and
that's currently underway okay
a couple things
that I can't confirm I've only gotten
some information from the letter how
I've not read the letter so I'm not sure
exactly what that says so I can't
confirm nor deny that that was on there
so businesses
a school district in New Jersey as well
that's that's true you mentioned the
connections potentially
you're saying
you're not in the church and also what
the connection to the school district
and you in New Jersey was I know the
talk about them having been a part of
that Community but
the school district can't comment
comment on why he was threatening that
specific School District we just know
that he did have some connections to New
Jersey but that was years ago so we
don't I'm not sure why he was bringing
that up so late in the game in the
church the church I have no information
on that as well
that's true yes can you
can you update that claim if you have
found that to be unstated because
obviously once the suspect's body was
found I think all clear was given on the
campus so if you just give us an idea of
how that was a family unsubstantiated
yeah Stu in our interviews with uh the
shooter's father uh we brought that up
to him and he had mentioned that his son
does not have any friends he pretty much
sat in his room most of the time he ate
went to the bathroom in there so he he
pretty much never left his room and his
father didn't believe that he had any
friends let alone 20 of them that would
would help him put this out so we kind
of determined that he was the Lone
shooter in this it is all of that done
before
yes yeah well actually yes that's
something I would have to let deputy
chief Rosman answer to as far as when
the all clear was given but just what we
did with our investigation
what can you tell us about the timeline
of getting those claims disproving them
and wear alerting families
sure and I would point out that it's
it's easy to in hindsight look at this
was happening very rapidly what I will
say is at the at the time that that
information was received that the note
was found in his pocket we had already
established established not only a
unified Command Post in the field but we
had activated our Emergency Operations
Center and information was being shared
lifetime between uh the unified command
post our Emergency Operations Center
operating under our instant command
system and so that's the reason that we
were able to get information so quick
from the scene where the shooter was
found the note in his pocket and relay
that information lifetime to the people
uh like myself that were making
decisions on what information was
accurate to communicate with the public
and you know at the time we had to make
a decision whether we believe that the
the statement about there being 20
people involved was credible based on
the information that we had at the time
and I stand by that and we continue to
stand by that we do not believe that to
be accurate and that's why we did what
we did so thank you for the question I'm
gonna go somewhere else
because your firm put out a tweet at 12
28 a.m saying there is no longer a
threat to campus so at that time when
that tweet is put out your department
has already been made aware of the claim
of 20 other Shooters and it's already
improve in order to book the internet we
had already received information from
the scene very detailed information from
the scene and we processed that
information and made that decision yes
that's the answer yeah hold on hold on
in the back right there news there oh
yeah a quick question for chief says
being on the president uh two sosby will
you be releasing the body camera video
from the Larch and Cedar Street like I
have a previous investigations that are
coming on
when we are involved in a situation like
this we our policy and procedure is to
release the video however this
investigation is being conducted by the
Michigan State Police and campus police
so we will leave that determination up
to them as to when that value you've
done it with a couple officer involved
shootings while State Police are still
doing their investigation yes that's
true and in in cases that we do do that
we are in full cooperation with the
investigating agencies in this case and
then for the president real quick um
Berkeley Hall is closed for the rest of
the semester the unions close for now
what happens after that are you
ridiculous for a remodel like
um Oxford did are they going to be
completely torn down and rebuilt uh like
standing Hub or what's the process our
leadership group is meeting and we're
making determinations on the disposition
of each of the buildings in in real time
so I don't have an answer for that at
this point question
I know there's a lot of questions we're
going to do our best to get to all of
them so in the back on the suit and Tech
um I'm sorry a suit and tie right behind
yep good uh any reaction on the fact
that gray because of that female was
2019 and the licenses was able to
purchased these two handguns
to follow up on that uh
we were going around that that even
turned out for a job at MSU
and that could have possible loaded
I'll adjust the second question first
and I'll see if anybody wants to to take
the first
um that is part of the investigation in
terms of his connection to MSU we can
find no connection to MSU at this time
he was not a current student faculty
staff or a former student faculty staff
um we are aware of that claim as well we
are investigating it and I don't have an
answer for you right now but it will be
reviewed as part of our investigation
I will address the charging question can
you ask it again please
yes my understanding is that the in that
case the motion was made by the defense
uh and then before that motion was
pushed through to a decision that the
prosecutor then prosecutor of Ingham
County chose to uh drop that charge and
negotiate down to a lesser uh crime
which gave him no jail time no felony
charge for him and him from buying
additional weapons in the future and
you're a probation
but that that prosecutor is no longer in
Needham County Department
more hindsights is
big deals are happening all the time but
we would all hope that the a prosecutor
would would uphold the the law as it's
written there's always room for uh some
type of discrepancy or discretion
however that one will be under
scrutinized for for a long time I'm sure
did purchase the gun legally he was
allowed to purchase the gun there was
nothing in place to prohibit him from
purchasing a firearm
right here right
when New Jersey
I think that's something that obviously
we're going to look at obviously you
know in hindsight judging what
um mental illness somebody has is very
difficult without some type of formal
diagnosis
obviously in this case there appears to
be indications that that may be the case
it's going to be difficult to confirm
that but I think that's a question that
we have as well is did is if he did have
any mental illness and did it play into
this particular incident and we'll be
looking at that comprehensively as part
of our investigation
yeah
you can share possibly how close you are
to
emotive anything
yeah again like Lieutenant Gonzalez said
you know that's a difficult question and
we've said that from the beginning
it appears based on the content of the
note that he felt that he was slighted
in some way by people or businesses
um
did a mental health issue amplify that
or was it a component of that we're not
sure at this point
um I just want to assure everybody that
that's the the question on all of our
minds
um and we're working our best to to try
to determine that as best as possible
and we've committed to sharing accurate
information and I don't have an accurate
answer for you right now other than to
say that we continue to look at that and
attempt to determine the actual motive I
was a member of the church I don't have
that information
right here yeah very cheap one
um please report a lot of misinformation
and false reports coming in Monday night
some of that information was broadcast
on the scanner which we know a lot of
students who are listening to in real
time do you think that contributed to
the Panic on campus most definitely
um
misinformation is you know it's
self-defined by how it's stated right
and
um if that's what's going on what else
do you have to believe
if you're listening actively listening
to a scanner that's why we were
communicating in the manner that we
weren't please utilize us as your source
for information
with that so related to that there's a
couple points that police put up reports
that turned out to be false so of a
shooting at I am East for of someone
actively shooting as late as 11 30 PM
did those false reports you were getting
make your job more difficult and how did
you determine what to put out on Twitter
or send out an alert so those were
reports received through dispatch that
is then coming to uh to us uh the way
that the uh the coordinated operation
how we set up is that there were teams
assigned to buildings
and then we had response teams that were
set up to respond to calls
we operate on trying to verify and go
from there and so when we receive calls
like that if that's what you hear on the
scanner and that's how we're being
dispatched we're sending officers to
that location those officers get there
they get to Imes no signs of shooting
not hearing anything
that's the response and so how does it
decided to put something Twitter or
making alert well as we know that there
is a scanner that people may be
accessing in so when we have the
opportunity to uh verify or to confirm
that it's not true then we do that
that's part of the overall decision
making process with that what is the
value of doing that at that particular
time as they're putting out 11 30 that
there's like someone actively shooting
because without
to talk about the decision making for
that
it would have been based on what
information that was used at that time
to have that decision with that it's all
it's all real time it's very Nimble with
that and that's why we should be the
source of information
the case in the classrooms across campus
and is that best practice
to not have a locking method most K-12
schools for instance in these instances
have a mechanism for teachers still
that's true well that yeah I'm not
familiar with the statistical
information for K-12 but
would be the fact is that we have 400
buildings as opposed to maybe one or six
with that and so the sizes are
definitely going to vary with that our
practice currently is to not outfit each
and every classroom with mechanisms like
that
um there are a couple of reasons why or
why not two that's in a discussion in
itself on the advantages the pros and
cons with that
um however you know those components
these coming days and discussions we're
going to have with our community is to
we're not going to really lead the
discussions but we'll present options
and as a community we'll decide on how
we proceed with different physical
security
police officer presence potentially
security officer presence additional
security systems all of those will
become part of it with that but today
that is that is not how we're set up in
all of our classrooms with that
you mentioned that students rendered Aid
each other we are reports that possibly
one of the students killed acted
heroically and and tried to take the
shooter down
um can you verify those reports I
noticed so very early in the
investigation I couldn't speak
specifically to that action with that
you know we lots of information
um being fielded at this time what I
shared at the beginning of this press
conference was what was shared directly
with me by individuals involved with
that I would again wouldn't be surprised
if that were the case but at this time I
just couldn't confirm that that actually
took place and then a very quick
follow-up um I I know that you mentioned
we're not going to be identifying the
five students who are still in the
hospital are you able to confirm that
two of them are exchange students from
China
is that something that you can speak to
no no not not at this particular time
with that we do know that there are we
do have some International students but
couldn't firm confirm at this time where
their home country is
let's go in the back here over on the
left oh yeah I just wanted to maybe this
for MSP you said that you were able to
complete his journey from campus to the
site where you shot himself he had all
the same condition that kind of leads
you to believe it
more I mean was there could you was
there any point in there where they seem
in a hurry what did he stop at other
places and kind of contemplate doing
something or was he calmly walking home
it looked like from from looking at the
video that we did have portions of that
he was just walking home where his uh
ending spot at Lake Lansing large was
just around the corner from his house on
how on Howe Street so it appears that he
was just heading home where's the church
or the warehouse anywhere in the area
like it it seemed like there was a
Direction he was going no it appeared to
to us that he was he was heading home
when someone just spotted him from the
uh from the picture we put out on him
neighbors have said that they called the
cops about hearing shootings at the
father's house for those who not
responded to if you don't mind is
everybody okay if I call them people is
that okay
I appreciate it I was trying to keep
things on a tad bit orderly it's okay
I'll come back to you though
um uh right here the man in the black
Fest
University
I believe we are a strong community and
we will not allow a single individual to
take our University from us and we heard
that loud and clear from many of our
students we are still processing but
this is our home this is our University
that brown jacket where the training
guns purchased after the arrest
and you know how can you clarify where
they refers I don't know if we have that
information
I don't think we're prepared with that
information right now we may be able to
share that in the future we just don't
have it right now so
in the back go ahead
sorry about that yeah just multiple
neighbors have said that they did call
the police about issues of hearing
gunshots at the father's house or does
not responded to or the believer is not
accurate on that what the information
that we have is that those are not
accurate we checked all our call logs
along with our dispatch logs and we have
not received the Lansing Police
Department has not received any calls
for any shots fired at that residence
I talked to two students who have been
Distributing a petition with about 11
000 signatures for some sort of Zoom or
online option that's a semester it's
similar to what's offered at Oxford High
School has there been a discussion of
that in the administration yes we've
discussed that and there's ongoing
discussions do you see that as a
possibility we're considering all
options for the manner in which we
continue the continuity of Education
research and Outreach on this campus has
there been talk of differentiating for
students with classes in the union Amber
here who are in those classes options
different for them for the rest of the
student body or whatever Solutions sort
of be applied to yes we've been talking
about places and spaces and where
education will continue
um and certainly those two buildings are
Central to some of those conversations
thank you thank you
yeah there's been a lot of details today
about you know what was in the note
we're up what exactly was in the know
I mentioned earlier about it possible
why you know can you say what what
possible you know about motive to this
point
so again I I really do think we've said
all we can about what we think the
motive might be
um I I commend and appreciate the
Michigan State Police sharing as much
information as they have about that note
um I really think that's all we have to
share at this point we'll continue to
evaluate that note from a lot of
different angles a lot of investigative
Avenues if we determine anything else if
that note is of any additional value we
may share some more information in the
future but as of today I think we've
shared what we can in terms of the
content of the note
let's do one more question
um
right there go ahead I shouldn't die yes
this is for you I do want to practice
that we do want to share those stories
of students and officers
you previously mentioned that there was
an overwhelming police response so I
need to ask when Craig was able to exit
the end of the MSU and delete when you
get out of the campus and then we found
almost four hours away
when we talk about this massive police
response how is this not something that
was found especially if it sounds like
he was walking
yeah definitely you know in like we've
talked about already today
um the the chaos that that ensued and
the uh the information that we were
receiving
um due to the number of reports that we
were receiving on campus
um we actually at the time thought that
he was still on campus I mean we had no
indication at the time that he left
campus
we were receiving and responding to so
many calls about potential shots fired
or sightings of this person on campus
although we deployed resources off
campus we didn't receive any calls we
didn't receive any calls whether they be
valid or not off campus
as additional law enforcement resources
arrived from all over the state of
Michigan from counties away we started
to deploy those resources out almost if
you picture kind of a ring so if there's
our incident we kind of have our inner
and then we kind of work our way out in
different Rings that's how we started
deploying our resources we started with
campus our goal at the time was to
ensure the absolute safety of every
student and every person on this campus
after the shooting and that's where most
of the calls were coming from and that's
what we were really focused on we had no
indication at the time to believe that
he was off campus and especially that
far off campus two three four miles so
working through our unified command post
as resources responded we started
deploying them out further and when that
call did come in due to that decision we
had resources that were able to quickly
respond to that that location
um I know it's something that uh in
hindsight can kind of be questioned how
did he get from from point A to point B
um with nobody seeing him or no law
enforcement seeing him and all I can do
is assure you and the community and our
our students that we were acting on the
best information we had at the time
making uh critical decisions that that
we still stand by in deploying our
resources in the most efficient and
effective way possible to ensure the
continued safety of Campus which which
we did so even though the calls
West
there was never a surrounding of these
buildings where these calls were coming
out of do you believe it sounds like
you're saying there was just a sense of
Hysteria it's possible it would just
slip away
yeah you know I'll compare it to the the
openness high school shooting for a
situation uh The hoax situation when
that happened we all thought that was
real
um when the additional calls came in
that there were additional shooting
scenes on campus we thought those were
real initially we responded like they
were real we reacted like they were real
we sent tactical teams and inserted
ourselves into those buildings and our
officers following their their training
uh in their Drive uh entered those
facilities ready to hunt somebody down
and take them out and prevent them from
ending uh any other life and that's what
we did it took us a while to determine
that some of those were false were hoax
uh calls so as we were working through
that information we were actively
responding to those those scenes uh and
deploying our resources
and you know it it took us a while to
determine you heard it everybody here it
sounds like was listening to the scanner
I mean we were listening to the same
thing a lot of those calls sounded real
when they went out we thought they were
real and we responded like they were
real and we were ready to to
um do what we're trained to do
so I do want to say that we all have a
lot of questions particularly me who my
daughter was I was getting live updates
about what was happening in real time
and transparency is one of the um
priorities of the the board so as as new
information comes I'm expecting fully
that we'll all be apprised I did want to
add one update um Sparrow has called and
let us know that one of our students has
moved from critical to stable condition
and so I just want you to continue to
pray for those families pray for the
families who will be having Services
over the next couple of days for their
students who have
have not made it they sent their their
students to Michigan state for a quality
world-class education and now they are
they're holding services for them so
just hold them a space for them in your
hearts and continue to wish the best for
those who are still struggling but that
was the good news that we have at least
one who
has improved
thank you thank you
yeah
I already texted Warren because stable
is not a condition
awesome
thank you